for months now we've been hearing from
Republicans about the Biden bribery
Scandal now if you're wondering David
what on Earth are you talking about what
Biden bribery Scandal that is the right
reaction because it is a Biden bribery
scandal with very little bribery no
evidence and a whistleblower no one's
been able to speak to for three years
we'll get to that in a moment but the
new development here is that our friend
Democratic Congressman Jamie Raskin has
now released the transcript of the
Ukrainian oligarch who supposedly was
involved in the bribery saying I've
never even spoken to Joe Biden this is
yet it if you're paying attention this
wouldn't be a surprise but if you were
one of the people
who has been only Loosely hearing about
Biden bribery and maybe thinking any
second now the other shoe is going to
drop and we're going to find out about
Joe Biden's crimes then you are going to
be quite surprised by this Jamie this is
HuffPost Jamie Raskin releases
transcript of Ukrainian oligarch denying
he talked to Joe Biden they did the
bribery but they never spoke barisma
co-founder mikola zlichevsky who
Republicans claim bribed Biden says in
the transcript no one from his company
ever had any contacts with Vice
President Biden that is extraordinarily
clear
as the article explains Republicans
claim there's evidence a barisma
executive apparently slashevsky pay Joe
Biden a five million dollar bribe when
he was vice president in exchange for
unofficial favor they've demanded the
FBI hand over a document reflecting a
confidential sources conversation with
sligevsky Raskin has now countered with
a document of his own a three-page
transcript of a 2019 interview between
slochevsky and an acquaintance of Rudy
Giuliani who at the time was publicly
seeking dirt on Biden on behalf of then
president Donald Trump this is a quote
from slishevsky in the transcript quote
no one from burisma ever had any
contacts with Vice President Biden or
people working for him
during Hunter Biden's engagement when
asked if Vice President Biden had
assisted him or his company in any way
slashevsky says no slashevsky says no uh
in full disclosure this next paragraph
is relevant and then we'll move on to
further analysis in 2015 a barisma
executive named Vadim pasharsky thanked
Hunter Biden in an email for having the
chance to meet Joe Biden at a Charity
Dinner other guests told the New York
Times They don't recall Joe Biden having
any substantive conversation with
pasharsky it was a handshake by all of
the evidence that we have so think about
the multiple layers here now if I came
to some of these conspiracy theorists
and said okay
the guy from barisma says he never met
Biden they could say well the bribes
happen through intermediaries even if
you didn't meet Biden people working for
you could have met with people working
for Joe Biden okay hypothetically that's
possible number one we have no evidence
of that and more importantly number two
the claim here from slushefsky in the
transcript is very clear no one at
barisma not just slashevsky no one at
barisma has had contact with anyone
working for Joe Biden so this rules out
it precludes the possibility of this it
was intermediaries now I think it is
important to remember that every aspect
of this story has fallen apart it's also
important to remember
that if Jamie Raskin had access to this
transcript Republicans also did because
this was a transcript related to I
believe it was the impeachment of trump
one of the impeachments of trump so not
only have Republicans like James Comer
and others been insisting that this is a
thing absent evidence
Republicans if we understand this
correctly had access to the ex this
exact same transcript dating all the way
back to at least a few years and yet
they continued to make claims like this
claim uh oh I'm sorry they continued to
make claims that they have evidence of
bribery but when they were questioned
about it they said things like the
following here is James Comer admitting
we don't even know if these supposed
tapes that we have proving Biden bribery
are legitimate when will you be able to
confirm if these recordings are legit
never is that gonna take well I can
confirm that the recordings were in the
1023 remember I was with Senator
Grassley when we saw the unredacted
version okay so because Grassley was
saying alleged yesterday so these
recordings are legit you can confirm
they are legitimate they were I can
confirm they were listed in the 1023
that the FBI redacted we don't know if
they're legit or not but we know that
the foreign National claims he has them
there you go so this was like one of the
first of a thousand signals that this
may not really be what some of these
Republicans are claiming that it is we
have alleged tapes from a purported
whistleblower
flaming okay we're like three layers
removed already and we actually have
very very little here is James Comer
being interviewed by Sean Hannity these
this is not new material this is just
kind of painting the picture for you
about why we shouldn't be surprised that
this is evaporating before our very eyes
like when you pour water on cotton candy
and it just becomes nothing uh here is
James Comer saying well yeah The
Whistleblower with the tapes we also
kind of like haven't spoken to The
Whistleblower in three years with
respect to the tapes look it mentioned
in the FBI form that the oligarch had 17
tapes of Biden two with Joe Biden
accepted the broad that he used that as
an answer this is a high-ranking was a
high-ranking member uh or owner of
barisma
yes that is exactly right so have you
had anything can you show them
unfortunately nobody's had any contact
with him for the last three years you
know the MSNBC makes fun of me when I
said that there are a lot of people that
were involved in uh the Biden
shenanigans that that are are currently
missing but with respect to this guys
why will you not jail Biden on the basis
of alleged tapes we don't have from a
whistleblower no one's found for three
years isn't that enough to imprison
Biden for life so again if you've been
following this show for a while uh we
have not been ignoring the Biden bribery
story we've been covering the Biden
bribery story for what it is which is a
series of unfounded allegations with
evidence they don't have from
whistleblowers they can't reach and now
the latest is hey we have a transcript
from 2019 where the guy who supposedly
is going to blow the blow the roof off
of this thing actually says I haven't
spoken to Biden my staff hasn't spoke
talking to Biden my staff hasn't spoken
to any of Biden's staff there is just
nothing here Joe Biden committed a crime
investigate prosecute jail him if that's
what the law says I'm not going to stand
in the way but right now it is all like
wet cotton candy leaving crumbs
evaporating before our very eyes hey
here is something really really funny
uh Sandra Smith is an anchor on Fox News
and She interviewed former Trump
economic advisor Larry Kudlow Larry
Kudlow was asked by Sandra Smith hey
explain why the economy actually is
terrible I mean okay the stock market's
up GDP is up unemployment record low
black unemployment record low wage
increases uh higher than they've been in
a very long time consumer confidence is
up inflation's down Larry I it all looks
so good but explain why the economy
actually sucks and Larry Kudlow
struggles to do so because the economy
actually doesn't suck extremely
unpopular look at any point but this is
by Dynamics is it not part of Economics
yes sir I mean they're they're they're
embracing that this is their messaging
and this is their push sir isn't this a
woman and now they're putting a label on
it Larry I love the label uh middle out
lower up or lower end whatever stay over
your skis but wait let me just tell you
I was an abject value we're growing at
one percent the level of consumer prices
has gone up 15.6 percent since February
21. they didn't deliver all right and
guess what's not going up 15 your income
your wages real wages are getting
clobbered for middle and lower middle
class workers people are working the
pandemic jobs have come back Millions
more jobs than what was lost during the
pandemic have been created inflation is
at its lowest point since April of 2021
I mean every single one of these claims
is bogus I have a thing to do with that
well wait they're getting I just have to
bring this up and I don't I rarely
interrupt you Larry please I know I'm
honored markets are up okay there's
these there's there's key economic data
points that are coming out that make it
look like this economy every single
piece of data we have is sure making it
look like the economy is okay Larry
isn't going into a recession and the
left right now is saying haha to all
those who said Doom and Gloom look GDP
is up there the the country's growing
despite everybody saying that these
policies are awful so please explain
that disconnect from what the White
House is touting to what people are
feeling and actually experiencing war
against fossil fuels the massive
regulatory war against businesses both
large and small okay the tax increases
on companies and uh uh the inflation
record he doesn't even know the talking
points he does inflation down 11 months
in a row lowest since April of 2021.
businesses record profit profit stock
market up GDP up but there's a war on
fossil fuels well seems like it's a
failing War Larry or at least one that's
not hurting companies all right so
Biden's First full year in office which
is 2022 we grew at 0.9 percent
as a terrorist I got it I got it all
right in the first quarter now the first
quarter was revised up today I think it
ticked up to almost two percent or two
percent yeah uh the Atlanta fed GDP
tracker is looking at one point okay so
are we going into recession these are
very sub we should be growing
we should be growing at four five six
percent okay we really shouldn't I mean
you know this is a bigger macro economic
thing but the reality is
the bigger and wealthier a country gets
six percent GDP growth is not really to
be expected unless it's a rebound from a
big dip like for example what we saw I
think it was Q2 2020 because of the
pandemic it was record low numbers and
then predictably Q3 of 2020 was record
high because it was a bunch of recovery
it is not a reasonable expectation to
say that a country the size and at the
level of development of the United
States in normal circumstances would
grow at six percent a year you know we
we talk about China I don't know that we
actually get real numbers from China in
fact Chinese GDP numbers China claimed
very very rapid GDP growth for a while
and we now have reason to be skeptical
of those numbers but even if those
numbers had been true
you often see countries that are in a
more developing stage the way that China
was 10 years ago
with those numbers but it would not be
standard in the United States by any
means and this is Larry Kudlow bouncing
around well inflation and War on fossil
fuels and oh but this number that number
but it was revised up this is what it
looks like when you don't really have a
case to make it's not a case to make and
then he mentioned something about AI
it's just he's all over the map this
guy's coming today and it's not red and
it is not blue
um rich I want to bring you in here
because what's happening though and why
what I just asked Larry about is is this
disconnect you know the markets seem
okay Larry and people are saying are we
really are we are still not answering my
questions Marcus got clobbered last year
clobbered down 20. okay so this is a
real comeback rebound uh that has
nothing to do with anything this is
about Ai and Technology what listen Jay
pal what does that mean this is about Ai
and Technology AI is now responsible in
2023 for low unemployment High job
creation declining inflation solid stock
market growth G GDP growth consumer
confidence and wage increases I would
love to hear Larry Kudlow explain how AI
is responsible for that really
interesting economic views they happen
to be Fantasyland nonsense and it is not
a surprise that they're struggling
because we still have problems nobody's
saying anything's perfect
but by every traditional economic
measure things are very okay at minimum
certainly good enough numbers to justify
the re-election of whoever happens to be
president it just so happens to be Joe
Biden
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
well the bad news for the failed twice
indicted twice impeached former
president Donald Trump couldn't possibly
be getting any worse just when it seemed
that maybe that judge Eileen Cannon
appointed by Trump might be his Saving
Grace in the federal classified
documents case we have now learned that
special prosecutor Jack Smith might be
preparing to hit Trump with 45 more
charges in that classified documents
case including potentially putting those
charges forward in a different venue
like for example New Jersey where
Trump's Bedminster Resort is located
which also appears to be the scene of
some of these alleged crimes in order to
get around the possibility
that that trump-friendly judge Eileen
Cannon might be able to run interference
from Trump what is all of this about
well let's explain it first and foremost
daily news report special counsel Jack
Smith could hit Trump with up to 45 more
charges interesting Trump the 45th
president could be facing 45 more
charges special counsel Jack Smith is
reportedly ready to drop a hammer blow
of up to 45 additional criminal charges
on Trump in the classified documents
case especially if Trump friendly judge
Eileen Cannon looks set to thwart the
case this is a super important detail
once we knew about the location of that
first set 37 felony charges against the
failed former president being in South
Florida and once we knew that judge
Eileen Cannon had been randomly assigned
to the case
understandably I and you and many others
said wait a second
someone Trump appointed is now going to
be involved in the disposition of this
case that seems absolutely ridiculous
and it is ridiculous and there are calls
for her to recuse herself Etc but
shortly after that legal experts
realized or put forward the idea
that hey you know what
not all of these alleged crimes happened
in Florida yeah Florida's where
Mar-A-Lago is and Trump had the bathroom
document dumped there and all that but
some of this stuff is very clear
happened in Bedminster New Jersey you
could charge Trump elsewhere in this
case and that is exactly what is being
looked at here the daily news article
says the ex Brooklyn prosecutor is
prepared to bring additional charges in
various Federal jurisdictions against
Trump based in part on multiple
additional incriminating tapes of trump
now I want to make sure that people
understand this because you know these
Mega people will go oh they're just
coming up with ways to go after Trump no
no no no no no
uh first of all Federal prosecutions
have latitude in terms of where you
bring charges secondly the tape right
the the audio recording where Trump has
heard shuffling papers like Rush
Limbaugh used to do and then showing
people and saying but this is secret
this is classified that took place in
Bedminster so it is not a stretch to say
that Trump would be charged somewhere
other than South Florida uh prosecutors
are reading what is known as a
superseding indictment in part is a
backup plan in case Canon seeks to stall
or derail the case against Trump
that was filed in the southern district
of Florida in which Trump's Mar-A-Lago
Resort home is located new charges could
come in the coming weeks one likely
venue for these additional charges would
be New Jersey because Trump allegedly
kept and even showed off some of the
highly classified documents to his aides
at his Bedminster Golf Resort Smith's
team is poised to stack on an additional
30 to 45 charges on Trump as well as top
aides based on what the paper described
as fresh evidence that is not yet
publicly known including more tapes of
trump so there are even more recordings
that have not yet been released even
though we of course have some of the
tapes that have been released here as
well important to also mention this is
separate from the potentially
forthcoming federal charges against
Trump related to the January 6th Trump
Riot Insurrection for which the January
6th Committee of the last Congress
referred criminal charges to the justice
department that's being investigated we
have the state charges in Georgia which
quite frankly if you zoom out of all of
this the state charges in Georgia may
end up being the most serious and or the
most consequential for Trump or waiting
on that we'll know about it out of
Georgia sometime between middle of July
into beginning of September I believe it
was those are the dates
uh so this is this is we are nowhere
close to we are nowhere close to the end
of this entire thing
I you know because we're so patriotic
here on the David packman show wouldn't
it be great if 45 got 45 more charges
dumped against him during fourth of July
week I think that would be a very
exciting thing hey remember how Trump
referred endlessly to Elizabeth Warren
as Pocahontas because of the belief that
Elizabeth Warren had based on family
history and stories that she was part
Native American
you're you may or may not believe this
failed Republican gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake now says she's
probably native American now I I'm not
taking any position on whether Kerry
lake is or isn't Native American I had
people writing to me saying you know
from her look she may be Native American
I am not touching that with a 10
football I have no idea if Kerry lake is
Native American I have no idea if Kerry
Lake uh believes she's Native American
or looks native I'm not getting anywhere
near that
but the idea that now
she is putting forth I probably am
Native American is hilarious after all
of the Fiasco around Elizabeth Warren
supposedly wanting to use her Native
American little all that stuff Harvard
admissions it was all debunked Okay
let's listen to this here's Carrie Lake
who lost who lost that race okay very
important to remember she lost in that
she got fewer votes than her opponent
um here she is speaking to Erica mataxis
about Choctaw blood or whether she's
black and then she goes actually I do
think I'm Native American nobody's more
all-in than you are and I it just
Thrills me and of course I secretly hope
that you will uh be president Trump's
vice presidential candidate do you have
any like Choctaw blood or or or or or uh
African-American in your back anything
like that that would you know I am I'm
just um American I'm a little bit of
everything and we probably do have a
little bit of Native American in our
family because of where my grandparents
are from in Wisconsin I know sure but I
never I'm just an American I'm a mixture
of everything
um and I always consider I'm gonna guess
Chickasaw no I honestly you um what does
that even mean you're such a bright spot
you know in in in in the political
future of the country and what are you
talking about this guy by the way if
you're not familiar with this Eric
mataxis guy imagine how deluded and
disconnected from reality you have to be
to look at the Panorama of uh look at
the landscape of Republican candidates
and and people you know Hangers On
and say that Kerry lake is the bright
spot on in the American right wing
that's crazy then Kerry Lake of course
uh told the story of how a very powerful
person tried to bribe her out of
politics and this is a story we all
doubt seems like one of these they came
to me with tears in their eyes stories
and every time she tells it she tells it
a little bit differently and I don't
know if I told you this I didn't put it
in the book because it kind of happened
after I'd finished writing it I probably
should have added it but couple months
ago I had a call from a very powerful
person in Arizona and said I have to
come over and talk to you in person this
can't be done on the phone which I was
like okay okay uh shows up at my door to
offer me a prestigious job title right a
procedure a large salary and a position
on a board if I will just promise to not
run in this next election 24. oh sweet
and I said really I said do you are you
serious I walked away from a prestigious
job I walked away from money I'm not
motivated by that
we talked a little longer I finally got
him out of the house that's actually
funny when when mataxis goes do you know
why and it's like he's just he's just
being conversational but it's a great
question why on Earth she lost what's
there's there's no big threat from Kerry
Lake right now I mean sure Arizona is a
very 50 50 state if she runs for Senate
which we'll look at her talking about
she could win but what she just lost why
would you immediately try to bribe her
out of politics it makes no sense and I
I said he said how much would it take
what would it take just just because the
Chinese have Deep Pockets come on for
two years is just don't get on the they
don't want me on the ballot they don't
want Trump on the ballot because they
know we the people will show up and vote
in droves and they know that if they
pull another rigged election
it first of all it's gonna be a lot
harder because now we know every which
way that they're cheating right every
single one of which court said didn't
happen and I think they know they can't
pull another one like that
so that makes me think I need to stay in
politics as dirty as it is I haven't
decided what I'm going to do next there
is a senate seat that's going to be uh
for grabs this uh go around oh boy and
right now we have uh Kirsten Cinema who
votes with uh Joe Biden 95 of the time
that's not representative what the
people want all right and then so let's
hear from just another interview on this
Senate thing this is a different
interview uh where Kerry Lake was asked
about the whole Senate thing and she
acts like she's a martyr listen it's not
that she wants to continually inject
herself into politics it's that she
might have to the book is available
wherever books were sold unafraid but I
I gotta find like what are you gonna do
this book is great you're gonna be on a
book tour and uh but there's a senate
seat with your name on it some people
think uh there's a big opening
potentially uh you know competitive race
there are you going to do it I'm
considering it I really seriously am
yeah um I need to get through this I'm
looking at it I know that all the
polling is showing that we have a real
advantage here and with a three-way race
I mean Arizona needs somebody who's
going to go to DC and represent the
people right we have a current senator
in that seat who is voting with Biden 95
of the time we have a socialist running
on the Democrat ticket who is all right
so anyway this is the same these are as
you can see in every interview she uses
the same lines you've got someone voting
for with Biden 95 of the time so she may
just have to do it she may have no
choice potentially Native American Kerry
Lake might not be ending her political
career just yet this long National
nightmare will not yet be over we're
going to keep an eye on it and you can
be sure that she will claim she won even
if she loses again remember all of our
Clips will be on YouTube
they will be on Tick Tock they will be
on Facebook they will be on Instagram
and most recently one of these clips
from today will be on Snapchat which is
a whole other world altogether don't
even get me started on that
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show the
Supreme Court on Friday dealt another
defeat to President Joe Biden blocking
his student loan forgiveness program CNN
reports in a stinging defeat for
President Joe Biden the Supreme Court
blocked the administration student loan
forgiveness plan Friday rejecting a
program aimed at delivering up to twenty
thousand dollars of relief to millions
of borrowers struggling with outstanding
debt the decision was 6'3 Chief Justice
John Roberts wrote for the conservative
super majority this will become an issue
in 2024 Biden can try to Galvanize
liberals by claiming the conservative
Court prevented him from delivering that
relief to voters Republicans are
celebrating the ruling as a defeat for a
bailout plan
um republican-led States and
conservatives challenging the program
say it's an unlawful attempt to erase an
estimated 430 billion dollars of federal
student loan debt under the guise of the
pandemic Roberts said the Biden
Administration and Secretary of
Education rewrote the law
that it cannot fairly be called a waiver
it not only nullifies existing
Provisions but augments and expands them
dramatically however broad the meaning
of waiver modify that language cannot
authorize the kind of exhaustive
rewriting of the statute that has taken
place here I have to tell you this is
not surprising every time we we talked
about this for example on the bonus show
a David Pac-Man membership costs six
bucks a month yeah
Pat and I both said
this is shaky while we agree with the
policy
This legal basis is shaky and people
would call in during live calls and say
David should I stop paying my student
loans I owe nine grand should I stop
paying them because it might all get
paid off
and I said don't take that advice from
me it's not obvious to me that this is
going to survive
and it's not obvious to me that it makes
sense to allow interest to continue
accumulating while you wait for this to
work its way through the courts and
indeed this was the decision so listen
the Supreme Court has handed Joe Biden a
number of defeats by now the most
important the most important takeaway
and realization from all of this is
none of this would be happening
if Hillary Clinton had defeated Donald
Trump in 2016 and I know that there are
people in my audience who don't want to
hear this there are people who stayed
home or voted wrote someone in or
whatever in 2016.
under the guise that Hillary's just too
conservative for me yeah okay Trump's a
clown but not that different from
Hillary Clinton and there were people
like me and others who were saying
that's really dangerous were not just
pretending that the Supreme Court issue
could be a major issue it really could
look now Roe v Wade student loans I
can't even give you the full list
most of this stuff doesn't happen if
Hillary Clinton wins in 2016. with
rumors now of potentially multiple
retirements in the Supreme Court
upcoming I am going to restate again and
again that the Supreme Court could be a
major issue in the next presidential
term
and it is really important that we
remember that and we take 2016 as a
lesson as far as that goes so this is
the Supreme Court's decision this is a
loss for Joe Biden it is not a massive
surprise
uh but it is a reminder about the
importance of the Supreme Court and
we've got a horrible Supreme Court right
now I mean that it's it's the reality we
we have a horrible Supreme Court we will
continue following it we will see what
other venues there may be if any for Joe
Biden to do student loan forgiveness
there are he could have done it with a
different legal justification we've
talked about it before we will talk
about it again but that is the Supreme
Court's decision let's talk now about
2024 Republican presidential candidate
Chris Christie the reason I talk about
Chris Christie is not because all of a
sudden I'm a republican the reason I
talk about Chris Christie is not because
I think he's going to win the Republican
nomination I will get to that in a
moment the reason I talk about Chris
Christie is because the contrast between
a republican who is connected to the
real world but whom I disagree with on
policy and the rest of these clowns
could not be a Starker contrast today
Chris Christie appeared on Fox News a
couple of days ago and it is remarkable
yes he's pounding Trump he's going after
Trump he's ridiculing Trump he's saying
things about Trump that the rest of them
aren't willing to say but it is
remarkable how different his entire
demeanor and approach is to this
Republican primary he's almost certainly
not going to win and we'll talk about
that in a moment but listen to Christy
say things that are not controversial
and say them in a way that they all
should be saying them but nobody's
willing to do it other than Chris
Christie but my view is he's let us down
didn't build the wall Mexico didn't pay
for it didn't repeal and replace
Obamacare like he said he would Sam's
gonna balance the budget he didn't and
you mentioned debates look we should
have debates and everyone should be at
the debates and folks should go to
chrisgrizzy.com donate and make sure I'm
on the stage
but Donald Trump should be on that stage
too if you want the Republican
nomination the Republican voters have
the right to see us right in those
cameras and have us compare and then let
them choose
um and and American people are good at
that and we did but they need all the
information and that's what we want to
give them the fact is if Paul don't put
my stock into the polling well what
would I put that's what it is today you
know you know what they ask you how they
ask those questions you've been called
by posters they say if the election were
held today well if the elects were held
today I'd be shocked because the first
election is not going to be in January
in Iowa January of 2024. we're six seven
months away from that now so let's run a
campaign I I don't think we crowned
Kings in America you got to work for it
and Donald Trump needs to work for this
nomination
do y'all become friends again does he
offer you a cabinet post again do y'all
clean this up I think it becomes the
nomination I don't think so I think some
of the some of the stuff he's called me
um over the last few months
um I don't think that's going to happen
and and that's sad but it is the truth
of the matter and it's his doing but
you're not closing the door to voting
for him no I'm saying I can't support
him you won't vote I can't support
either one of them okay not Biden or
Trump because they're not competent and
qualified to be president for different
reasons Joe Biden predominantly because
of his age and what we've seen on TV and
Donald Trump because I don't believe he
can win Lawrence you know when you're
under this much criminal scrutiny and
the conduct by the way that he's engaged
in taking those documents keeping them
in his home making sure that his own
lawyers didn't get to see all of them
not telling the truth to the justice
department when they wanted those
documents back and now saying that what
he was saying on a tape when he's waving
around document well I was lying then
well I think Mama Jones and I know my
mom would say the same thing you're
lying once I'm not going to believe the
other time too we need to have someone
who's honest direct and who can beat the
Democrats because I'm tired of losing
Chris all right so listen this is not
remarkable stuff what's remarkable is
how remarkable unremarkable stuff sounds
from Chris Christie because no one else
is willing to say this stuff now it's
not lost on me that I'm sure it's
extremely triggering for Trump to turn
on Fox News which at one point was
extremely friendly to him as Trump says
and now they allow other candidates to
express their views it's not even that
Fox News is no longer friendly to Trump
it's just other candidates have other
views and they think they're better than
Trump this is not about glorifying Chris
Christie as the moral whatever Christy
stood behind Trump literally and
metaphorically for years and went with
all of the stuff and now all of a sudden
he's willing to say these things but
still it is a good thing to meet Maga
where they are and many of them are
still watching Fox News and that's why
it is a great thing to have Chris
Christie saying these things it is not
good for Trump to have a guy capable of
coherent and provocative sound bites
attacking Trump it's not good for Trump
will it make a difference I I don't know
and this is where I get to okay I want
to have this conversation with you as
well
uh people write to me
and I see the comments and they say
David you loser Chris Christie's not
gonna win
I never said Chris Christie was going to
win I'm not supporting Chris Christie
it's almost like just because I
recognize that Chris Christie's the only
sane Republican running a normal
campaign I want him to win and therefore
if he loses you've defeated me I'm not
voting for any of these people but it is
crystal clear crystal clear that if you
said one of these Republicans is going
to be the next president it's not going
to be Biden who do you go with it is
obvious I go with Chris Christie now
some people will write in and say David
how are you defending Christy who's so
corrupt I'm not defending Christy what
I'm telling you is he's the only
candidate willing to tell the truth
about Trump who's not playing Coy who
isn't angling for either a VP slot or
Trump's Maga voters or whatever the case
may be now he's obviously not going to
win as a result Chris Christie went from
polling one percent to 2.5 percent now
he's down to 2.4 percent and an average
of recent polls 2.4 is not super strong
okay even if it's more than double where
you started so there does it's really an
indictment of Maga
that there is essentially no appetite no
appetite for just a normal Republican
who would do things they claim to like I
think Chris Christie would probably try
to lower the taxes of the people
Republicans try to lower taxes for and
you know he said he wanted the wall
built he's mad at Trump because Trump
didn't build the wall I mean it's like
he would more or less do the things I
thought Republicans wanted and he has no
chance it is an incredible indictment of
the modern Republican Party
speaking now on the Democratic side but
still talking about Maga there are a
hell of a lot of magalunatics that
really like Bobby Kennedy Jr Trump
advisors past and present respect and
celebrate and Revere Robert F Kennedy Jr
saying he's a patriot he's doing a great
service to our country he's bringing up
important issues related to vaccines and
other things I'm going to play a clip
for you we will talk about whether it's
a fallacy to do guilt by association you
all know My Views about Bobby Kennedy Jr
some in the audience say I'm too soft on
him some in the audience say I'm too
hard on him I just call it like it is my
friends but let's listen to what Roger
Stone and Michael Flynn and Trump's
lawyer Alina Haba and others have to say
about Bobby Kennedy Jr and then let's
really ask ourselves the most important
question
why do they say these things about Bobby
Kennedy Jr let's listen let's think so
I'm a great admirer of Robert Kennedy
he's a friend of mine I am a fan of
Bobby Kennedy so I want people to know
that I I actually look at him and I
think he's one of those like
um I I think I have a lot in common with
him because I'm a former Democrat I just
changed my party affiliation two years
ago if I were a Democrat I'd certainly
vote for him if I had any money I'd send
him a contribution but I don't I think
RFK junior is doing a great service to
our country I I am disappointed that his
party is so corrupted I mean he's the
perfect example of a true American
Democrat a two a true patriot who loves
this country I think he is potentially
an extraordinarily uh attractive
candidate at the end of the day however
I believe this is candidacy may serve
the purpose of softening Joe Biden or
Who ah whoever the Democratic nominee is
uh for the candidacy and defeat by the
man who will clearly be no matter what
the courts do the Republican nominee for
president
Donald J Trump I think it will help in
the end uh soften Joe Biden up for his
defeat by Donald Trump in the general
election he actually has a lot of a lot
of views that are actually uh I think I
think very beneficial across the board
I'm excited that he I mean he's he's
shining the light inside the Democrat
Party
Robert F Kennedy Junior's campaign is
getting traction for one reason he's
speaking truth to power so those are all
deplorable individuals and then of
course I played this very short clip for
you last week Trump also singing the
Praises of Bobby Kennedy Jr then we'll
talk about what this all means
Junior who I've known
a lot of people respect him he's got
some um
some very important points to be made no
he's a respected person so listen there
are two elements to this there are two
really important things to this first of
all
this you know when Bobby Kennedy Jr was
asked recently about Trump supports you
what do you think and he says no I'm
proud of that I think that's great
because we're Reaching Across the aisle
or whatever
the reality is
that when really deplorable people like
what you're doing it should immediately
make you ask a two-part question one Are
My Views also deplorable do does the
deplorable person like what I say
because what I say is deplorable or
does the deplorable person like what I
say or claim to like it because I'm
useful to them in some way and with
Bobby Kennedy Jr the answer sadly in a
sense is both okay now let's talk a
little bit about logical fallacies I did
this last week I understand that
strictly speaking guilt by association
is a logical fallacy saying Bobby
Kennedy Jr is bad because Trump likes
him that is guilt by association and
strictly speaking it is a logical
fallacy however we have to be able to
distinguish when guilt by association
should lead us down a path of
Investigation or not if I were to say
and I gave these examples last week
Hitler breathed oxygen so oxygen is bad
that doesn't make any sense you'd say
David sir we need oxygen please if I
were to say Hitler had a doctor who
drugged him up with every drug in the
world and was just a clown so therefore
doctors in general can't be trusted
that's silly wouldn't make any sense but
if I were to say Hitler like Mussolini
and Franco in Italy and Spain so that
should make me skeptical of Mussolini
and Franco that makes sense however I
should still investigate it and I should
say am I right to be skeptical about
Mussolini and Franco I would research
and I would go yes I am we have looked
into every aspect of Bobby Kennedy
Junior's platform or candidacy or
whatever and of course extraordinarily
concerning views about vaccines and
autism foreign policy weird statements
about Russia and China weird uh China's
ethnic racist bio weapon or whatever
statements about the 2020 election the
health policy Roundtable with absolute
medical lunatics on and on and on and
when it comes to Bobby Kennedy Jr these
folks like him for two different reasons
number one
he shares some of their views when it
comes to things like vaccines and Russia
Ukraine to a degree
Etc so in a sense there is an allegiance
or a similarity when it comes to
political positions but in addition to
that and risk this is really important
to understand
Steve Bannon has been talking up Bobby
Kennedy Jr and his conspiracy theories
for a while Steve Bannon isn't stupid
and Steve Bannon sees Bobby Kennedy Jr
as an agent of chaos he can generate
chaos he can generate chaos by
potentially being a stumbling block for
Joe Biden on the path to his
renomination he could be a stumbling
block for media that might not be
interested in a contested Democratic
primary or whatever the case may be this
is a huge part of why these folks are
now saying Bobby Kennedy Jr it's
absolutely great stuff
so the more we understand about what's
going on the more concerned it should
make us but not just because these
people like Bobby Kennedy Jr but because
of the positions he holds on many issues
as I've outlined to you over the last
several weeks
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Republican Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
who also is running for the 2024
Republican nominations suffered a woke
coma again this happens when he
uncontrollably repeats the word woke
multiple times this one I believe
setting a record in 19 seconds repeating
the word woke six times this was during
a speech late last week for the
extremist group moms for Liberty's
conference and I I want to make the
strongest argument I want to make for
you here
is that this is bad strategy I think the
anti-woke stuff is a loser for de
sanctimonious let's listen to what he
had to say it's mostly just the word
woke Florida we fought the woke all
across the board one and as president uh
I will fight the woke and the
corporations I will fight the woke in
the schools I will fight the woke and
the halls of Congress for we will never
ever surrender to the woke Mob We are
going to leave woke ideology in the
Dustbin of history there it is folks six
wokes in just 19 seconds we could talk
about how this guy is an uncharismatic
clown but we'll have more time for that
in the next segment about his latest
interview with Fox News okay so I won't
do that now we could talk about how
Florida is very mediocre it's not that
Florida is terrible it's just in most
metrics Florida is right in the middle
the Florida success story that uh Ron
DeSantis claims was that Rose Like a
Phoenix Over the Horizon of success in
Florida is a very mediocre story we've
talked about that before we're not going
to talk about that either
what I want to talk about is that this
anti-woke stuff is bad strategy it
definitely can't win you a national
election and it's not even clear that it
can win you a Republican primary either
yes DeSantis is a doofus his woke
Obsession doesn't make any sense but
look at this look at these numbers when
you actually talk to Americans most
Americans This is an ABC I'm sorry USA
Today ipsos poll finds most Americans
view wokeness as a good thing
56 percent of Americans say that to be
woke means that you're informed and
aware of social injustices that's more
or less the definition I've been using
56 of Americans have that positive view
of wokeness 39 of Americans say wokeness
is being overly political and policing
the speech of others that's a pretty
sizable margin right 56 to 39 a 17 point
margin for wokeness being a good thing
is quite remarkable given that the
country is 51 to 49 52 to 48 on so many
different issues that's not a sign that
running an anti-woke campaign is going
to win you a general election we have
another poll that's older it's a hill
Harris X full poll that one found that a
third of the country says I am woke a
quarter of the country says I am not
woke 13 don't know and 31 percent don't
know what wokeness is okay
it's a small margin right a third to a
quarter roughly 33 to 25 but that's
another poll that says actually you're
more likely to be woke than to not be
woke in the United States and then I had
this other poll I told you about not
that long ago uh the gist of which was
if you ask people hey do you think we've
done enough to like help trans people or
have we not done enough or have we done
too much more than half the country
believes we have either done the right
amount or not enough
a minority of the country believes we
have done too much to make trans people
feel welcome and comfortable which would
be like the anti-woke position and you
ask them this on racial inequality uh
LGBT gay marriage Etc you get the
anti-woke view in the minority on every
single one of these questions so for a
while we had a lot of good evidence that
anti-woke is not going to win you a
national campaign it's not even clear
that it's going to win Ron the
Republican nomination and the reason I
say that is just look at the numbers if
you look at this is a poll this is a
rather a chart average polling data for
the Republican primary the Top Line the
guy leading is Trump the purple line the
green line in the middle of the screen
is DeSantis and as you see he's been
bouncing between 20 and 24 percent since
he announced he's going hard and I woke
and it's not really getting him very
much in terms of new polling support so
obviously it's not going to to work
nationally it doesn't even seem like the
anti-woke stuff is getting traction for
DeSantis at the Republican primary level
and it really shouldn't given that
wokeness actually seems to be winning
let's now go to the lack of Charisma of
Ron DeSantis and we're not going to
spend a ton of time on this Ron DeSantis
was interviewed a couple nights ago by
Jesse Watters Jesse Waters is a Fox News
host who I I'm aware that he now is
going to be in Prime Time on Fox news
thanks to the firing of Tucker Carlson
and a sort of reorganization that went
on
um and Jesse Waters is horrible
but Ron DeSantis is so painfully awkward
and cringy here is the santis claiming
the left doesn't want people to be happy
and he's not really making a very good
case that that's the truth and after
ovens why does the government do that if
they just want to control you have an
itch on the left they want to control
Behavior a lot we saw the same thing
with covet a lot of that wasn't about
your health it was about they wanted to
control your behavior so they just don't
want people to be happy and be able to
make their own decisions they were going
after gas stoves in Florida we made them
tax-free we may have to do some
incentives for for the Coal Fire Pizza
because you know what uh we'll take it
they're going to want us to microwave
this pizza so you're wrong okay and
there's Ron DeSantis eating pizza eating
pizza you know you're really angering
liberals when you eat pizza on Fox news
from a studio in New York City this is
supposed to make the guy likable in some
way this is supposed to show us that
he's right on some policy issue it is
just pathetic then the topic by the way
of Gavin Newsom came up came uh came up
and Gavin Newsom is the Democratic
governor of California who has been
trolling DeSantis very hard very hard
and DeSantis actually has to lie to
criticize California which they love to
do what's with Gavin Newsom
well you know I was born and raised in
Florida I never saw a California license
plate my whole life in Florida and why
would you why would I now I know people
are going to write to me and say David
what is wrong with Ron DeSantis why why
does his head shake like that I am going
to remind everybody to our knowledge Ron
DeSantis does not have a condition that
would cause any kind of shaking or
Tremors uh nothing parkinsonian he
doesn't have tardive dyskinesia or any
of that if he did we would not be
pointing this out this is a move that
Ron DeSantis does to seem engaging and
laid back he just his his head moves
like a bobble head and he could float on
out of the screen if you're not careful
it's a very weird trait and he needs he
needs some kind of a personality
transplant Trump was right believe a San
Diego or or Los Angeles and yet since
I've been Governor we've seen a huge
rush of people moving clear across the
country to leave California leave San
Francisco leave out to come to Florida
nobody no California had never lost
population for its entire history lie
okay so that's not true and again it's
like States sometimes gain population
sometimes they lose it can happen for a
number of different reasons it doesn't
have to be because of awoke dystopia or
whatever the case may be but
there were multiple years in the 90s
when California lost population he's
hanging his hat on this is a new thing
it's not true until he became governor
and so I think he sees people leaving I
think he sees that there's deterioration
and I think he's lashing out do you
think Newsom is trying to be next in
line and jump Kamala Harris well you
know what I told him is stop messing
around on the sidelines like either do
it or not like are you going to take on
Joe if so step into the ring and do it
and so I think he's kind of maneuvering
in the in the background
um but you know that would be
interesting to see if Biden doesn't
ultimately make it uh how that resolves
it do you think Biden is going to make
it
look I think that people want to move on
from Biden I think that's very very
clear I don't know if he's going to get
that message and so he may very well try
to stick it out we'll be ready for for
whoever because I think the thing about
the Democrat Party is yeah Biden's got
huge problems we all know that but we
talk about this corruption what does he
have going for him Harris is his
impeachment insurance no matter what
Biden does nobody wants Harris and so
it's almost like just let him finish out
and by the way let him finish rather
than impeaching wouldn't it be good for
there to be something to impeach Joe
Biden over the sand is like a matter of
political strategy I don't know that
impeaching it makes sense how about is
there any reason to impeach him it's
sort of like the stuff with the crimes
does it matter that there's no evidence
of criminality nor charges nor an
indictment or no it's just like do we
want to charge him or not is really all
that matters at this point with these
people so DeSantis just making very
little sense and I'll be honest I don't
know who understand this actually is
getting any traction with it's certainly
not the broader Republican electorate in
when he goes to a diner it's extremely
awkward I don't know who likes DeSantis
here actually there's a woman that goes
to my gym who's been wearing a DeSantis
tank top for a while so I I guess I
could ask her
um here is DeSantis weighing in on the
Loyalty question that Donald Trump has
brought up so many times Trump says
you're disloyal do you feel that way
disloyal to who I mean you know
politicians have to earn support they're
not entitled to support I did a lot for
him in 2016 and 2020 by the way I was
happy to do it oh yeah but at the end of
the day
um you know I'm loyal to my family to
our Constitution and to the good Lord
and I have a vision I think I'm the guy
that can beat Biden but even more
importantly no more excuses on these
issues I'm gonna get all of this stuff
done we'll have a plan on day one to get
going and get cracking and give you two
great terms for eight years and really
get the country on a fundamentally
different path I think I'm the guy to do
it and so I have uh the responsibility
to step up and serve there you go and
you can really feel the energy and the
enthusiasm and the fact that DeSantis
really is going to get all of these
things done isn't he you can really just
tell so listen it's the entire loyalty
thing
um there these are both clowns when it
comes to loyalty I'm talking about Trump
and scientist Trump's view is DeSantis
isn't loyal because he decided to run
against Trump after Trump supported him
this is politics okay let's pull up our
big boy pants and let's realize that
this is politics this isn't uh you know
it's not gin rummy or whatever
um this is this is just kind of the way
it is and if you're going to be this
much of a snowflake Trump I'm talking
about it's going to be tough to have
success in other areas and Trump is of
course struggling for Success from the
point of view of DeSantis the idea of
invoking God and saying my loyalty is to
God rather than to Trump again it's I
know it's a small thing but it's another
one of these examples of how they
constantly have to drag in religion
to civil government positions he's
running for a position in civil
government should have nothing to do
whatsoever with God but he just can't
resist we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here's a question
based on something our friend Sam and
Emma said over on the majority report hi
David I'm watching Emma bigwind and Sam
Cedar on their show and and they're
saying that if it were the only two
choices the lesser of two evils
was Trump and DeSantis yep they would
vote Trump and that's that seems
ridiculous to me no no no no I agree
with that listen if you came to me and
you said the next president will be
Trump or DeSantis I get that Trump's
aspirations are absolutely insane but
DeSantis is much more likely to achieve
many of the things he wants to do I know
the January 6th Insurrection crazy so I
get it I get it but many of the things
Trump would like to do he will fail to
do DeSantis is likely to succeed and
thus I do believe
Trump is the less dangerous candidate
than DeSantis I'm glad to hear uh
conflicting or a disagreement from
people in the audience we have
conflicting thoughts or disagreement
from the audience we have such a great
bonus show for you today just get it get
get the bonus show it's very important a
David Pac-Man membership costs six bucks
a month exactly
joinpakman.com coupon code indicted
again we will see you then or otherwise
Wednesday we're off tomorrow for the 4th
of July holiday
foreign